we continue our series real food this
morning with a look at the growing trend
of kelp the seaweed is rich in nutrients
and antioxidants and is a common
ingredient in sushi lately it's been
popping up in salads and soups Michelle
Miller met a Connecticut fisherman
turned seaweed farmer who sees a future
in kelp Michelle kelp oh that's right
good morning everybody
well the ocean covers more than 70
percent of the earth it produces less
than 2 percent of the food we eat we
took a trip to the Connecticut shore to
discover how a simple harvesting
technique is paying off for fishermen no
longer able to rely on a steady supply
of fish they're betting that this
nutritious sea vegetable can be a
mainstay of the American diet these
waters off Connecticut's thimble islands
were once abundant with lobster shad and
flounder not anymore
that's why Bren Smith who dropped out of
high school to become a fisherman has
laid down his hooks nets and traps to
farm this what we're growing mainly here
is kelp he calls these sea greens the
next food trend try little stem you're
kidding right according to at least one
laboratory test kelp a variety of
seaweed has more iron than beef is high
in calcium and low in calories come on
fresh kelp grows well like weeds in the
fallen winter months and is then
harvested in the spring so we have
anchors going down to the bottom just
with ropes and then across eight feet
below the surface we've got a horizontal
rope and then we grow our kelp down from
there
and our job is to let it get enough
light and enough nutrients so we just
keep it at the right height in the water
column and that's cup Foreman smith
leases 20 acres of ocean from the town
of Branford Connecticut his start-up
cost about 20 grand he says in a good
year he can reap about 20,000 pounds of
kelp per acre and how much will you
yield in terms of profit yeah so we so
the net is about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars a year and we're able
to get about a dollar a pound
off the dock for centuries fishermen
have made a living off the coast of
Maine through the mid-atlantic region
but scientists say climate change and
overfishing have transformed the fishing
industry the oceans are just changing
and we need to diversify Smith says kelp
farming is a sustainable solution for
fishermen and the environment it takes
zero inputs to grow this so no
fertilizer no feeds no freshwater and
while we're growing we're soaking up
nitrogen carbon soaks up five times more
carbon than land-based plants we call it
the culinary equivalent of the electric
car this is where you bring the kelp
yeah
brent is also expanding his company's
processing plant in New Haven
Connecticut it's where the magic happens
oh wow right here this is where we make
our kelp noodles air foots hot fresh
kelp is first blanched Wow look at that
color chartreuse and then cut into
strips there we go
orders for these greens are 10 times
more than what they can harvest the
whole idea here is to use this
processing plant as the funnel into New
York City so we have farms from Maine
all the way down the coast and then
their product comes through here we
process it and then truck it out he
tricks it to restaurants like caseous
where chef alex de schinsky creates kelp
dishes that are newfound delicacies to
his customers what is it called
kelp bolognaise chef lish insky is
turning the table on how people view
seaweed it's not just for salads anymore
these are candy Benny seeds
although he does make those with a twist
this is better than I thought it was
gonna be
that's simply delicious Brent Smith is a
nonprofit organization Green Wave have
helped establish 10 kelp formers this
year and the he hopes just sign on about
15 more by next year the goal is to get
fresh seaweed sold in supermarkets and
on menus of really popular restaurants
and how's it taste it tastes great two
completely different tastes briny
crunchy yummy fresh out of the water and
then when they blanch it it loses that
salty taste right it is a perfect pasta
yeah all right you gotta taste the bull
your name okay you love it kelp is a new
cave let's do it even real let's go me
and my baby are ready
ha ha ha oh the baby's ready for Kelvin
o Canada linear rate equivalent of the
electric car like that always good to
have you here Michelle